how do we push back well we get good
people involved and one of those people
of course is Elon Musk and now there's
something interesting going on with this
Twitter thing right now because one of
the things that's happening is that uh
you know Twitter because once you say
hey I'm gonna buy your company and then
the company has to open up the book so
that you know the guy buying it knows
that he's actually buying what has been
promised what's happening now is as
they've started to open up the books
some weird stuff is going on it's like
oh how many Bots are there how many of
these accounts are fake we thought maybe
it was five percent it's looking like it
could be 20 if not more he's finding out
all sorts of stuff so now the deal is
looking a little bit shaky but we have a
little info here from the daily wire
which is Ben Shapiro's website and Ben
Shapiro is a very can we get that image
up one more time before we throw to this
text here Ben Shapiro is a very very
scary guy
[Music]
all right here's Ben Shapiro's daily
wire on what's going on with Elon and
the Twitter machine
in late April Twitter and musk agreed to
a deal worth 44 billion but musk had
previously requested info on fake
accounts before his purchase of Twitter
could officially go through he has
claimed that spam accounts could have a
massive impact on what Twitter is
actually worth on Monday the SpaceX
founder took his demands a step further
by sending Twitter a detailed letter
through his attorney as Twitter's
prospective owner Mr musk is clearly
entitled to the requested data to enable
him to prepare for transitioning
Twitter's business to his ownership and
to facilitate his transaction financing
musk's attorney Mike ringler wrote a
letter filed with the SEC at this point
Mr musk believes Twitter is
transparently refusing to comply with
its obligations under the merger
agreement which is causing further
suspicion that the company is
withholding the requested data due to
concern for what Mr musk's own analysis
of the data will uncover
based on Twitter's Behavior to date and
the company's latest correspondence in
particular Mr musk believes the company
is actively resisting and thwarting his
information rights and the company's
corresponding obligations under the
merger agreement Wrangler remark this is
a clear material breach of Twitter's
obligations under the merger agreement
and Mr musk reserves All rights
resulting there from including his right
not to consummate the transaction and
his right to terminate the merger
agreement so this is really fascinating
stuff and you know when I talk about
Twitter I get it a lot of you are not on
Twitter because you're wise people when
I went to the locals uh breakfast in
Orlando a lot of you say that now locals
is your only social media which is
fantastic but the truth is whether
you're on it or not it does exist it has
a certain amount of influence in all of
those things so musk says he's going to
buy it and now he's under uncovering
that it's been a huge amount of [ __ ]
right so it's not just that they censor
certain people and we know they're
always censoring people on the right
nobody on the left is being censored on
on Twitter okay and the hunter Biden
laptop and kicking Donald Trump off and
Shadow Banning and all of those things
but now that the accounts themselves are
fake and what in what ways could Twitter
or whoever's really controlling Twitter
in what ways could they have really
changed our political uh dialogue if
they could have sent all sorts of bots
to hate certain people and not hate
other people or promote certain people
and not promote other things or that the
New York Times has you know something
like 50 million followers but rarely
gets 10 retweets right I mean all of the
[ __ ] is being exposed and maybe what
Elon Musk really was planning to do here
and man would that be a tip of the cap
to Elon Musk maybe he was really never
planning to buy the thing and his plan
was hey I'm going to offer this crazy
amount of money so that they'll have to
say yes but I know that the whole
thing's [ __ ] right because he's got
insiders he knows what's going on and
I'm going to expose that it was all
nonsense and then I will let it collapse
under the weight of its own crap and
then the shareholders will probably all
through the board and Sue all of the
executives into Oblivion because they
were running a giant shell game so this
is sort of like an Enron or a Ponzi
scheme type situation so all the guy
wanted
in essence was this thing to be more
pro-free speech or at least to expose
the nonsense and the entire machine is
freaking out on top of the fact that
then for weeks we've seen articles about
how he's really racist and he grew up in
South Africa so he's obviously racist
and everything else so what do you do
you fight back that's Elon way elon's
way of fighting back